Akil and Liat for inviting me to talk in
this workshop and thank you all for
being Gareth we're excited to talk about
this work with all of you this is joint
work with Nicole my club is right here
Jacob leshner who is also right here
behind the call and Brendon Lucia who is
not here but he's at Microsoft Research
in New England our serving points today
is going to be the standard college
admissions of many to one matching model
so in this model we have students who
have preferences over colleges and they
can each be assigned to just one college
college is also have priorities over
students and then they have a quota but
the number of students that can be
assigned to the college outcome in this
setting is just a matching of students
to colleges for each student we assign
them civil college making sure that we
don't violate the quotas in the setting
a common solution concept is stable
matching in a stable matching no student
college pair can do better by matching
to each other and stead up to their and
so if we want to get to a stable
matching then we'll what should the
market look like or what should the
Clearing House look like we should use
something called deferred acceptance and
typically how this is implemented is we
have some central clearinghouse everyone
reports their full preferences to the
clearinghouse and then we take these
preferences this input into this black
box deferred acceptance algorithm we
output the final assignment of students
to colleges
okay so this is what's typically done
but the question we're going to think
about today is what if people don't know
their own preferences what are they
going to report to us and how can we
reach some kind of good maybe stable
outcome when people don't know where
they want to go in particular maybe
people don't know their preferences and
it's costly for them to learn their
preferences so for example and college
admissions or school choice maybe
there's some sort of cognitive effort
you have to look up the different
colleges and sort of decide what you
want and which the colleges
those maybe there's actually a monetary
cost or time you have to go and
physically visit these colleges in
hospital residency matching similarly
medical students have to pay
out-of-pocket to go and visit these
prospective Hospital placements and so
that can cost them up to thousands of
dollars when they're going through this
process okay and so if people don't know
their preferences and it's costly for
them to learn their preferences then
maybe there's a way we can use the
marketplace to help guide them in
acquiring their preferences and so what
we're going to do today is look at the
marketplace as both a place that
determines the final assignment of
agents to objects but also facilitates
the acquisition and transfer information
between all the different participants
and they're working well this in mind
we're going to ask the following
questions
how do existing matching mechanisms
affect student information acquisition
and can we design clearinghouses that
facilitate efficient information
acquisition for all students I'm gonna
be a little more precise later about
what I mean by efficiency
this is where I'm going first I'm going
to set up a model and solution concept
for this matching with incomplete
information so and my model my market
outcome is going to consist of both a
matching as well as how much information
has been acquired so an information
state and then stability has to be
defined with respect to this information
in a particular the information
acquisition is going to be endogenous
just sort of the state on top of this
I'm also going to define a notion of
optimal information acquisition and I'm
going to put all of this the stability
with optimal information acquisition
into the solution concept that I call
regret 3 instability after I set up the
model and the solution concept then I
can start asking well how can we reach
such a solution concepts how understand
of matching mechanisms perform if they
perform poorly what can we do better and
so I'm going to show indeed they can
perform for lis standard mechanisms can
get stuck in these what we call
information deadlocks the idea is that
in a matching market if I don't know my
preferences well how i acquire my
preferences depends on what's available
to me which depends on your preferences
but how you acquire your preferences
depends on my preferences ok so we have
these kind of circular dependencies
where everyone's optimal information
acquisition process depends on everyone
else's and so it's very easy to
construct instances where you just get
stuck and Oda for anyone to do an
optimal thing they want to wait for more
information they want to wait for
someone else to act first
and so what we say is well this this is
a problem that we can't get around just
by cleverly designing mechanisms what we
do is we we need more information to be
injected into the market at the
beginning to sort of jumpstart this
learning process so what we say is well
first of all let's characterize what
these regretfully stable outcomes look
like we show they all exist exist and
there's a sufficient statistic for
characterizing them and in terms of
these admissions cut-offs and then so
what we need to know then in the market
is just what are these admissions
cut-offs and we provide some ways for
estimating these cut-offs maybe using
historical data and showing some results
that show that we can bootstrap this
information to reach an approximately
optin welcome there's a lot of related
literature on information acquisition
and market design as well as notions of
stability and matching markets with
incomplete information another related
strand is sort of the communication
complexity of matching markets what our
solution concept is trying to do is we
define a notion of stability in these
incomplete information settings and then
we want to minimize the cost in some
sense of getting to the stable outcome
and so that's quite related to
communication complexity minimizing the
complexity of communicating information
is kind of similar to minimizing the
cost of acquiring information and on top
of that we're going to be using a
particular model for costly information
acquisition this is based on the
whitesman Pandora's box model but there
are a number of different related models
you could sort of think about what
happens if you take these models and
embed them in the matching set
let me introduce you to our model we're
in a many someone matching setting where
we have a finite set of colleges college
I has a quote a Qi for the number of
students that it can admit and then we
have a continuum of students and we have
a distribution over these students I'm
going to describe these students in just
a moment in our model we have just one
sided incomplete information so the
college priorities are known make
college priorities of public and they're
encoded here by this RSI I've been told
that ours should stand for it reverse
rank because if you have higher rank
higher reverse rank than you are
preferred
so over here student 1 has higher
reverse rank at college I then student 2
and therefore some someone said that
ranks smaller ranks are better ok but
here the larger ones abetik and so ok
again colleges have these publicly known
priorities where our larger priorities
better and students have incomplete
information over there
preferences we specify what a student
does know here's a student her name is s
she has a value B si for attending
college I so this is a cardinal value
that she obtains for attaining for
attending this college but she doesn't
know this value what she does know if
she has a prior F over the distribution
of her value and she has one of these
for every single college and her values
for the college just are independently a
drawn from these priors what she can do
to learn are valued as she can go and
visit or pay this cost si si
for learning exactly her value at
college
so again the student starts off with
initial information she knows her prior
she knows her cost and she knows her
rankings relative to everyone else in
the market and that's all she knows and
so if we were in a single agent model
some of you might recognize this as just
the Weitzman Pandora's box model for
consumer search right each of the
college is the box and the student can
pay the cost to learn her value exactly
at a particular box
yes
so now we have all these pieces and an
economy is just given by the set of
colleges their quotas the set of all
possible student types in a distribution
over this set of student types and this
also implies a distribution over the
these sort of initial student types what
students know about their information
together and an outcome in our model
consists of two parts
there's the matching which is just an
assignment of students to colleges but
on top of that we need to keep track of
how much information has been acquired
in this market and so we encode that
here by these inspection indicators so
Chi SI is telling me it's one if and
only if student s has inspected college
i and otherwise it's zero i'm just
because the only information acquisition
the students can do is inspect colleges
i'm just keeping track of which colleges
so it is to be a model with convenient
yes yes so you should think of this as a
model of the continuum oh yeah I'll get
to the assumptions and just wants light
on top of one last piece of notation I'm
gonna take this bold curly s you should
think of this just as giving me the
space of all interim student types so as
students are acquiring information about
their values they sort of know more than
they initially tense they need no more
than theta but they still don't know
their full vector of values okay so this
is just that if you're somewhere in
between if I have inspected college one
now I know my value at college one nice
to only know my priors at all the other
colleges and so this is my actual values
these are the colleges I've inspected
I'm just taking an equivalence between
sort of these student types which are
indistinguishable and given these
inspections
but all you need to remember is that
there's an S which is a student type
including their values there's a theta
which is the initial type and then I
bold for the interim tempo notation here
are assumptions the assumptions we make
are that students must inspect a college
in order to be a match to that college
or ice fine to that college we make this
assumption for a number of reasons one
of the main ones is just for
tractability if we were to do this
single agent if we're looking at just a
single agent problem and we wanted to
let students take boxes or attend
colleges without inspecting them then we
end up with this Pandora's box with non
obligatory inspection allora doble has a
paper on this which basically says that
the optimal policy is really complicated
even for ended for one student and two
boxes
so for tractability and so we can get
some nice closed form solutions we're
gonna assume that you have to inspect on
top of that we also assume that students
have strict preferences this is just to
make sort of some notation and things
easier and when I say things about
uniqueness using strict preferences and
if they're not straight we're just going
to break ties and some fixed me and on
top of that we are assuming that this is
a continuum economy in particular
students are going to be non-atomic
and on top of that we have something
that can call this consistency condition
but you should think of this as meaning
there's no aggregate uncertainty about
aggregate demand okay so if I look at
about aggregate values so if I look at
all the students who have this initial
type data associated with that is a
prior over their values at all the
different colleges and then if I look at
the actual values of this set of
students that distribution is exactly
equal to data
yeah so in unlined with that first
assumption they call it students must
inspect the college does that mean that
the prior beliefs have to have the same
support like you couldn't have a prior
belief for value that's note with
probability 1 less than the value for a
given college the relative ranking well
you could still have let's let's say we
had this instance where the the support
for one dominates the support for two
then you would just not be assigned to
two and you wouldn't have inspected
without having to inspect them yes so
you only have to inspect the one that
you're assigned to choose to it with one
is all available to you so you'll never
human conspiracy obscure so the value
file coordinates to
yeah so I am thinking of a setting where
your cost could perceivably it change
whether or not you choose to let me get
to the single agent model and I think
[Music]
for each time you have come to think of
it as you know there's some there's some
finite number theatres we have a finite
number of types data and we have a
massive series
spread them out over the priorities
your questions about the model great so
let me get to the single agent problem I
mentioned before you can think of the
single agent problem just as the
Weitzman Pandora's box problem so what
is that problem initially the student
beta knows that her value for college I
it's distributed according to this prior
F this is what she can do is she can
dynamically or adaptively choose to pay
her inspection cost to inspect school
colleges and then based on the result of
that inspection decide what to do next
for example here the student might
decide to she looks at her priors she
thinks it's worth the cost to see how
much he likes college one she pays the
cost she inspects it boo she discovers
that she has a value zero for college
one that's not very good so she decides
to let me now go and inspect to college
to she inspects college two she sees
that she has value one she thinks of
great I'm just going to go to college
too and not bother with inspecting
college three so here's one example of a
strategy that the student could use and
what we're trying to do is yeah solve
this problem adaptively select a subset
of colleges so that I'm maximizing my
value this is the best value that I've
observed minus the cost of every college
that I've to pay the cost for every
college I inspect but I only get the
value for my favorite one
and this single agent problem has a
really nice solution you can with a
little massager and recast it as a
multi-armed bandit problem from which it
follows immediately that it has a given
index policy which is optimal this was
shown by Weitzman in 1979 the policy
looks like this first for every college
I compute the outside option value that
makes me indifferent between paying the
costs to inspect the college or taking
the outside option this is saying is
that my expected marginal benefit from
inspecting is the same what I do i
compute one of these for every single
college I ordered them in the order of
these goodness indices and I inspect
them in that order until one of my
inspected values is bigger than all the
remaining uninspected indices so the
order is given by so I compute this
index this index is a deterministic
number and then the order is given by
the decreasing values of the indices so
I'm expected taking the expectation over
my values so this value is distributed
according to the F I mean just the order
I was wondering whether there's some
prior information
Savage so that there's one college I
don't like then I know all the others
I'm not gonna night for sure because
exam day I think they're worse that's
not at all
no so there's knows no kind of
restriction like that at all in this
model of your value for different
colleges and run independently so
learning one doesn't tell me anything
about my values for all the different
colleges are independently distributed I
can pay my cost to learn the value at
one college this gives me no information
on my values for other colleges but it
does affect whether I'm willing to then
pay the cost inspect other ones because
I observe a very high value then I need
the value is higher than this this index
for another college then it's no longer
worth it for me to inspect
everyone understand the single agent
problem the problem turbulence if the
students acquired them for me
and one shot why do you also impose this
good question yeah so our goal is to to
ask so the question was to think of a
setting where students acquire all their
information in one shot and then we run
the Clearinghouse we add is asking it
seems like we're incorporating some kind
of dynamic information acquisition why
is this necessary so the idea is that in
in in a matching setting where we have
these dynamics it could be that after I
learn part of my values after I learn
some information about my preferences
this can reduce the amount of learning
that you have to do so we're going to
allow for the student we're gonna take
these single agent problems and now
allow them to be interleaved with each
other
say okay well yeah you go and select
college one okay tell me what you're you
found okay now Nikhil you go inspect
college too we're going to see if by
having all this additional power of
having a dynamic mechanism where we
enter leave all these different
inspections we can reduce great so we're
going to allow ourselves to have that
full power of dynamic mechanisms I agree
it's not realistic in this setting to
expect that we can do this we're going
to show a negative result that given
particular restrictions and the
information that we can provide even if
we allow for this full dynamic
interleaved inspection we're not going
to get to a good outcome
I still haven't defined the good outcome
but it's coming but we'll show that if
we use the right information we can do
something that looks a lot more like
what the two of you are proposing which
is one round of the the central
clearinghouse gives some
information kind of information to all
the students they separately do their
information acquisition based on that
information and we come back and got
their preferences so that's sort of what
we're doing with this decentralized
they're giving ourselves the full power
possible but restrict in in sort of the
time dimension but restricting what we
can do in the information dimension and
showing that that's not that's not the
right way to make things so maybe it'll
be clearer once I get through all that
part of the talk we just inspect until
he finds one what he sees is really
better and then he stops and he takes
the one that he had seen which was
better than which for which he would
have non- expected he is dependent on
the B's are independent across agents
and independent between friends
so you said you go and visit that school
and then you tell me but I don't learn
anything from that because I don't learn
anything except so I don't learn
anything about my preferences I do learn
something about which colleges I could
be admitted to right everyone wants to
come to Berkeley please great then if I
am really low priority at Berkeley then
all of a sudden I think maybe I
shouldn't pay the cost to figure out how
much I weigh
if it's one show that we have the
contradiction yeah yeah yeah so so yeah
let's let's talk about one shot versus
dynamic offline
reminder here is what we're allowing
students to do I can dynamically inspect
colleges and can decide to not inspect a
college if the cost of doing so
outweighs the marginal
this model does is it rationalize this
some behaviors so in the single agent
setting this is where students know the
set of colleges that admit them students
made optimally choose to remain
partially informed so in this example
here the students decided not to find
out how much she likes college three
because she didn't need that information
Judy knew she wanted to go to college to
where or it was not worth the cost to
her to find that information
on top of that in the multi-agent
setting what we're adding now is that
every student said if admitting colleges
depends on other students preferences so
I don't learn anything about your
preference my preferences from your
preferences but I do learn something
about which school which colleges would
admit me in which colleges would not so
in particular let's say this student
over here really wanted to go to college
one but based on all other students
preferences she she finds everyone else
wants to go to college one as well and
she's she doesn't have high enough
priority to go then it's really not
worth it to her to go and visit College
one and and verify that indeed yes I
really like College one because I mean
and so you might not want to inspect
colleges that don't admit you on top of
that let's say you're given multiple
offers at once let's say we're in some
kind of matching market where there are
multiple rounds of offers of admission
let's think I don't know PhD admissions
sometimes there are some multiple rounds
there and so students may want to hold
on to multiple offers and delay decision
making until they have more information
about what other students are doing so
let's say a PhD student here here's this
PhD student and she has offers from PhD
programs two and three but if we look at
her optimal policy she really wants to
figure out how much she likes one first
in fact it's it's quite likely that
she'll look at how much she likes one
discovers she really likes it and then
just stop and go to one if one is
available to her okay but she doesn't
have an offer to one yet she only had
offers two two and three but it's not
worth it to her to decide which of the
two that she prefers at this moment
rather wait to see if she has a chance
of getting into life
okay and so we're going to call this
some kind of regret if student 1 were
forced to go and inspect and decide
which of two or three she liked better
then she may regret having to go and
acquire the information before knowing
the set of colleges that admit her so
let me pull all those ideas together
into our solution concepts which we call
regret free stability it's based on
classical stability so in classical
stability a pair student college pair
can block an outcome if the college is
willing to defect that is the student
has higher priority than some semen
assigned to the college or the college
isn't full yet and the student also is
also willing to defect this college is
better more preferred to the student
than their car this is in a setting
where students know their preferences
and then outcome is stable if there are
no blocking pairs let me just rewrite
this a little bit I'm gonna say a
college isn't a student's budget set if
this condition we had before holds this
is just say that I look at all the
students who are currently assigned to
that college who have higher rank than
me high-priority me there's not enough
of those kinds of students to fill the
college therefore I can still go to that
College and I block if I also then
prefer going to that College over my
current assignment so this is just
stability and a complete information
setting what I'm gonna do is now define
a notion of stability in our incomplete
information setting we say a collagen
serum block and outcome now an outcome
consists of both a matching and a
current information state and again the
pair blocks if the college is in the
students a budget set this is system
this is it's not full yet of students
that it for first student and the
student either inspected the college and
prefers it to their current assignment
or has not inspected yet yet but is
willing to pay the cost to do so so this
outcome is not stable because the
student can there's still more the
student can do she can go and inspect
the college
so you're running the first acceptance
after every new inspection this I don't
know if it's helpful to think of it that
way just think of it as I I drop you on
an outcome and some amount of inspected
inspection and you look at whether
everyone's happy with the outcome given
me this is just a solution concept I'm
not telling you how we got there and in
some ways it's similar to how we define
stability I'm just I'm dropping you
somewhere and asking if it satisfies
certain conditions where nobody is going
to deviate great question so instability
what I'm doing is I drop you at an
outcome and information and I say given
this outcome I don't want to defect to
another school and I don't want to
gather extra information okay on top of
that we're also going to impose that I
gathered the right amount of information
so here's where I'm going to impose sort
of this this notion of optimal
information acquisition so we say an
outcome is regretfully stable if the
matching is stable with respect to the
enquired information and the inspections
are optimal with respect so they're
matching okay so what do I mean by this
well here's the outcome I have a
matching I have a certain amount of
information that was gathered in order
to get to this matching and what is this
information I'm saying this information
should be the same as if I gave every
student their budget set from the
matching and said here's exactly your
budget set here's a set of colleges you
could conceivably block with those are
the colleges you can go to now go to
your optimal inspection on that set
why is that not totally captured by
yeah and so what it's doing is that
saying that not only is the outcome is
not only do I not want to inspect more I
haven't inspected too much in order to
get to this outcome I'm trying to
capture particular kind of regret so you
might think of one kind of regret which
is due to uncertainty about your own
preferences okay you had a good prior
for college you pay a cost to inspect
and you realize a low value maybe you
regret that you're like oh I shouldn't
have gone and inspected that bad college
but there's no way you could have known
that right based on your priors
okay but what I am ruling out with this
solution concept is I'm pulling out
regret due to uncertainty about the
market so in particular once all of them
I'm in this continuum economy right so
once everyone else has sort of realized
what they're going to do I know exactly
the set of colleges whether in my budget
set or that are available to me and so I
don't want to inspect one that's not
available to me that's a wasted cost I'm
also going to in that set I now have
this sort of optimal inspection order
where I want to make sure that I'm
inspecting in the right order and I also
want to make sure that I'm not over
inspecting so once once I have a really
good college I stopped inspecting yes
I yeah so this is a refinement of
stability so here's a concept of
stability that's our concept of
stability here this is fine this is this
is a definition of stability setting and
we're refining to sort of be more
precise about what we mean by what is
optimal information acquisition what is
the least cost that we have to pay in
order to get to a stable outcome and
which stable outcomes are consistent
with this least cost can you talk about
the efficiency properties over
regretfully stable because because I
might have acquired an optimal for me
amount of information there you might
not have been the socially optimal
information because as you said my
information acquisition affects how much
you want to do yeah so it's not
necessarily we're not saying anything
about utilitarian welfare we're not
summing up over different students we're
just and part of why we chose to do that
is we didn't want to compare these
utilities in costs between different
students but we're just saying that
given what everyone else has done you've
done the optimal thing for you but
everyone gave an optimal thing for them
might be very far away in this world
so typically stability kind of passed
some yes yes yeah so there is a gap
between this outcome and
define efficiency in terms of
utilitarian social welfare way you sum
up over everyone we're not making any
claims about that kind of efficiency is
it they both but can you repeat the
question
yeah so the chi is the schools I
inspected and the values that I saw yeah
I mean the Chi is the schools I inspect
and the values that I saw our primitive
of the economy so I those values are now
the values are deterministic they
realize at the beginning of time
so what I'm saying is that there is some
inspection in this outcome I'm going to
ignore it okay I'm gonna see what I
would have done if all I knew was my
budget set and I'm gonna compare which
colleges I inspected under this policy
versus the colleges I actually inspected
I want them to be the same yeah yeah so
this is our solution concept
and one question you might have at this
stage about the solution concept as well
this seems like a very strong solution
concept right essentially what I'm
requiring is that every student has full
market information before they do
anything they know everything about that
they need to know about everyone else's
preferences before they make their own
sessions does this thing even exist
it seems very strong ok and what we show
is yes it exists in fact we can show
that not only does it exist the set of
regretfully stable outcomes forms a non
empty lattice and this lattice is
ordered in terms of Dia how how much the
students value there matchings and we
also have some conditions for uniqueness
so how we show this is we actually show
that on top of existence this set of
outcomes has a very nice structure they
have they can be characterized by
market-clearing cut-offs ok so what I do
is I introduce cutoff and I say a
student has a college and her budget set
if and only if her priority is above
that cutoff
and her party's about that cutoff then
she looks at the set of colleges where
her priorities about the cutoff she
performs her awful inspection on that
set and this induces some demand and
this induces some aggregate demand when
I sum over all students and I want this
demand to be market clearing so it
exactly matches the quota of all of the
colleges this is just saying this is
some complicated object that I defined
where it's not clear how to reach it
algorithmically I just sort of dropped
you on this object and that satisfies
some properties but in fact here's a way
that we can characterize it using a
small number of cut-offs one for each
college
any questions so far
let me skip why we can do this kind of
structure it's essentially a reduction a
pretty nice reduction from this
incomplete information setting - we can
show it's equivalent to an economy and
the complete information setting and
then we can just port over all the
results from complete all like the
structural results from the complete
information so incomplete information
for the particular cutoff structure all
we need as that student preferences
satisfy the weak axiom in real review
okay so I've done a bunch of things I've
introduced you to a model with matching
with one-sided cost the information
acquisition I've spent some time setting
up this solution concept which we call
regret free stability I consists of two
parts of matching as well as acquired
information and we're requiring that the
matching is stable with respect to the
acquired information and the acquired
information is optimal with respect to
the matching parts of the solution
concept and so now we can come to the
question of well market design what what
should a market looks like look like if
this is the solution concept that we
want to reach we design clearinghouses
that facilitate efficient information
acquisition and this particular
definition of efficiency where we're not
asking students to over inspect given
their options but also resulting in
these stable outcomes
I'm gonna show you two main kinds of
results first is that standard matching
mechanisms kind of can't do this
and the problem is that they don't have
enough information they don't get enough
information from the students and so
they result in this deadlock where I
need to know your preferences to
determine my preferences optimally and
you need to know my preferences to
determine your preferences optimally so
how we can get around this is we can use
the cutoff characterization and if we
can learn enough information about the
cut-offs then we can get to an
approximately Alton welcome
the question is how can market guide
information acquisition one possible
solution is to allow for these the sort
of dynamic sequential communication
where the Clearinghouse aggregates
communicates preference information as
its acquired so I I get information
about yeah its preferences and tell them
to everyone so then so then you have
more information about where you might
be able to go so we define these things
called communication processes don't
have to think about them too much other
than the fact that it's basically we
communicate information from the
Clearinghouse to the student the student
takes the information along with their
private information about their type to
do kind of some kind of inspection and
reports the inspection result back to
the Clearinghouse and we can kind of do
this in as many rounds as we like and
interleave the students however we like
okay this is just some kind of
communication process between the
centralized Clearinghouse and the
students and we say that such a process
is succinct if at the beginning when
students have only information about
their initial types all naver can report
is their inspection indices so this is
the order in which I'd like to inspect
the college's here are my costs and here
are my priorities let's say we restrict
ourselves to this class of mechanisms or
is just the ranks the priorities
okay here's our main result let's say we
have a succinct mechanism that sort then
there exists an economy where the
outcome of this mechanism is not regret
for each day and what does this economy
look like it looks something like this
here's an economy where there are three
students three colleges each college has
two spots student one probably wants to
inspect college one first and probably
wants to go to college one but she has
top priority at colleges two and three
and I set this up cyclically so that
students who has taught priority at two
but once has top priority at one and
three but once it inspect to first and
three has top priority at one and two
but wants to inspect three first okay so
in this setting let's say I try to use
some mechanism like college revolving
deferred acceptance okay this is a sinc
mechanism it doesn't really use any
information from the students it just
looks at the priorities and says okay
you're a top-ranked at college too you
can go there if you want what goes wrong
with this mechanism is that well student
one really doesn't want to figure out
which of two or three she wants to go to
until she knows where she can go to
college one and the same is true for all
three students and so if we force any of
them to make a move to inspect then
they're going to be doing something sub
optimal or in other words they're going
to be paying the cost to learn the
market-clearing cut-offs instead of just
paying the cost to learn their own
preferences
yeah so so the general theorem is we
take sort of a gadget of this sort we
insert it into a larger economy just to
make sure that like we we have like more
seats and students we insert some extra
students make sure that there's only
certain things that can happen with
sibility but that's essentially what's
going on that we have this cycle of
students whose preference optimal
preference acquisition problems all
depend on each other's and so a student
must make an inspection first and that
is going to result in some kind of
regret and so we're saying is that in
economies with these kinds of
dependencies learning the
market-clearing cut-offs is more costly
than just having students learn their
individual
so yeah and then in discrete economies
so this is true even in a continuum
economy and the setting that we're in
but I've shown you this discrete example
because it really just so one question
you might have now is okay you define
this this solution concept it seems
strong it is strong in that we can't get
to it using things like deferred
acceptance or succint mechanisms in
general what should we do so what we can
do is the problem is not the solution
concept the problem is that we don't
have enough information at the beginning
if we're restricting ourselves to these
kinds of communication processes and so
we say let's take a communication
process with an Oracle we're going to
give it some additional information at
the beginning what in traditional
information should we give it in order
to to make this work and so kind of a
cheat is we can say well we can
characterize regret free stable outcomes
in terms of these market-clearing
cut-offs if we knew the market-clearing
cut-offs we could just tell them to the
Clearinghouse the Clearinghouse posts
these cut-offs they say if you're above
the cutoff then you can consider this
college and then this effectively
decentralizes the information
acquisition problems for every student
and they can just go do their own
individual optimal search on their
budget set and we'll get some kind of
outcome okay and actually and in this if
it's exactly the market clearing
cut-offs then we'll get exactly every
stable outcome
on top of that what we can do is let's
say we have we don't know the market
clearing cut-offs exactly but we have
historical data okay so we know last
year's cutoff and we know that last
year's economy is kind of similar to
this year's economy if you're they're
drawn from the same distribution then
what we can say is that we can post last
year's cut-offs have students act
according to those and this will give me
a regret free stable matching or outcome
for slightly perturbed capacities or in
other words if I'm willing to use to be
a little flexible on my capacities then
I can actually entirely remove the
problem of finding or paying the cost to
find the market clearing cut-offs and I
can have each student just pay the cost
for their individual information
so what does this mean for market design
well mechanisms like deferred acceptance
where we don't really tell students much
can incur pretty large regret if
students don't know these cutoff so they
don't have enough information about
aggregate demand to know which colleges
are available to them but they could be
doing pretty well if students do have
access to this information for example
if this is a market place that happens
year after year and there are cut-offs
and you can go look them up so we even
have a convergence theorem that sort of
says how close can do these capacities
need to be we also show that if
historical data is not available you can
use some kind of free information that's
available from the college priorities to
bootstrap this process and here's like
one way you can do that and we also have
some convergence theorems they're Van
Winkle cogent let me wrap up what we've
done is we presented a tractable
matching model with costly information
acquisition and show introduced vias the
solution concept that's regretfully
stable an outcome which is stable in
this incomplete information setting and
also making sure that students are not
paying too much cost to get to the
outcome these outcomes exist they have a
nice cut of structure as well as a
lattice structure but the broader
question is what is the role of the
marketplace in guiding information
acquisition and getting us to this
solution concept or other solution
concepts at all sure that existing
mechanisms can lead to informational
deadlock and incentives to delay
information acquisition and the reason
is that students need this market
information this aggregate information
to efficiently acquire their own
information so what this means for
market design is well maybe instead of
thinking so much about what mechanism
we're using we should think more about
what information we're providing so in
this particular setting all we have to
do is know the market clearing cut-offs
provide those to the students and
whether we had a good mechanism were not
for the actual assignment process the
students should be doing pretty well
[Applause]
so you publish this Clearinghouse which
is information about every college tells
you you can see where you're ranked
there and then you start inspecting and
what happens next
yeah so so so in the setting then or
this we post the cut-ups you'll do your
inspections and then you you basically
only apply and this in this particular
mechanism you only apply to your
favorite college out of the ones you
inspected which you know you can go to
of course in real markets things look a
little different to this that's because
in real markets the set up is also a
little different to our setup so there
are additional factors maybe you don't
exactly know your priorities or maybe
you don't exactly know the cut-offs in
those kinds of settings you'll have to
tweak this
because sort of like what you described
is similar to what's available right now
so I should clarify that in when we talk
about college missions we were thinking
a little about college admissions
outside the u.s. so in many countries
where it is just based on an admission
score you take some exams you take the
weighted sum of different exams and that
tells you your rank you're a relative
ranked how likely you are to get into
different colleges so I think what
you're proposing is maybe in systems
like the u.s. or in Canada where it's
not so clear how to calculate your your
score it might be useful to build a tool
that would be able to predict this for
you and I really think that's I think
that's true and there are also a lot of
informational interventions already in
place that sort of help help students
determine exactly as information which
colleges do I actually have some
probability of getting into I think
there's scope for that but I think in
most things with like personalized
predictions and assignment problems
there's there needs to be care taken and
how this is done so it suggests that it
would be a good idea for school
districts to tell people their lottery
numbers before they start thinking about
what schools to go to and we just
I know that doesn't really happen and I
wonder if that is that psychological or
like how could that be bad
why don't scold districts tell parents
but their lottery numbers are for their
kids
why don't they flip the coins before the
parents write down their preference list
yeah that's a great question
[Laughter]
I mean maybe four lottery numbers not so
much but for for the college admissions
it could create very homogeneous student
bodies because people may not apply
anymore to school and death they think
only 10% of people like them at that
school and then they stop applying and
then it's only 5% very important I think
that's a little different to what Nicole
was proposing
oh I
yeah
so being able to characterize using
cut-offs is really using that we know
one sides preferences fully but if we
wanted to just go to a one step back
just the definition of stability I think
if you were to have two sided incomplete
information where the the the structure
yeah yeah not that I think would be
possible then to even do some kind of
some kind of cut-offs where where you
have probability of being
concerning brother geography stability
concept introduced in the yeah it's a
great question
what about incentives we have completely
abstracted away from incentives in this
talk because we are basically saying
let's say we give the mechanism full
power what can it do definitely agree
that were great priests ability is not
going to be incentive compatible well I
guess in this large market it is instead
of compatible because you as one person
cannot effect but if if we were in a
discrete setting
I don't even know how to define
incentive compatibility because we need
like a game with what they think certain
colleges are looking for and they assess
you know what colleges they care about
based on how many other people apply
there so there's sort of this circular
talk about this especially the public
press side yeah what makes a good
college a lot of people want to get the
go there but you can't get in so then
they have to try to do things other
people who can't get it do and then that
changes some of the profile as well as
yeah everybody's trying to get pile SAT
school headed yeah and then everyone's
trying to play violin there are a lot of
interesting questions they can ask
what's the start letting people develop
their preferences in different ways
[Applause]